[Music]
the military needs to be deployed to our
southern border immediately to stop the
caravan of thousands of illegals pouring
into our nation right now is a very
dangerous time for Americans border
control is essential to your safety and
the safety of your family the military
the National Guard ice Border Patrol and
DHS needs to block this caravan from
entering our nation now I'm not saying
they're all criminals what I am asking
is who are they what I am saying is I
want to vet them screen them I want to
find out who among them is a criminal
who among them is a gang member like the
notorious ms-13 gang members who
arrogantly rode into our United States
by invitation during the Obama years and
are now in New York and elsewhere
brutally and savagely murdering innocent
American citizens I want to know who was
a pedophile who was a sex offender who
thinks they're entitled to beat their
wives I want to know who has an alcohol
problem who is a drug problem who likes
to drive drunk and who has no problem
hauling drugs for the cartel and if you
can prove that you're not one of them or
any other kind of criminal I want to
know what you have to offer us what do
you bring to this great nation what are
you going to contribute why should we be
proud to count you as an American other
than adding to the Democrats voting bloc
and continuing the mob mentality that
you have already exhibited you're
proficient at now if you're not a
criminal I want you to get to the back
of the line behind everyone else who
waited for a visa came here legally
hired a lawyer learned American history
and swore allegiance to this great
nation and only then am i interested in
even talking to you about entering I for
one am sick and tired of the sense
of entitlements that illegals have to
enter this country and then immediately
claim their constitutional rights as
they carry the flags not of America but
the flags of their country and god
forbid we try to deport them to the
country whose flag they so proudly wave
they have no claim on this country they
are not entitled to be here
they break our laws to come here now
this is not a left or right issue this
is a security issue a safety issue
we simply cannot have people about whom
we know nothing living next door to us
working next to us or driving next to us
crossers claim they're running from
violence in their home countries I spent
my career fighting on behalf of innocent
helpless silent victims of crime
victimized by violence criminals who
should have been stopped long before the
crime you're telling me you're telling
me because they're being victimized that
every one of them is a victim and
therefore entitled to come here as
opposed to anywhere else on the planet
go to the UN stay in Mexico now they say
their poverty is justification for
illegal entry I've got news for you
millions are suffering from poverty all
over the world
Haiti Uganda Zimbabwe the Congo
third-world countries so why is it just
Central Americans and Mexicans are the
poverty-stricken ones pouring into this
country by the millions why why because
they can because no one has told them
they can't because no one has stopped
them they come because there's a big
prize at the end
education medication housing food stamps
all the things that you pay for so you
want open borders look at what it's done
to Europe
if the left the mob and the demon rats
had their way there'd be rogue cities
and rogue zones all over the US just
like Europe with crime-ridden zones
where law-abiding citizens even law
enforcement are afraid to enter and for
good reason the left then the Democrats
in this country add an additional layer
of protection so illegal criminals
cannot be arrested in sanctuary cities
and states where American citizens are
thus put at risk these people don't want
a border wall have you ever asked
yourself why do you really think they
have a philosophical or no ideological
objection to the concept of a wall or
protection of course not all these bozos
are protected by doors and fences and
security yet they want our borders open
they want illegals to cross as a mob and
as a mob and unite around the state they
have no right to be in and register and
vote Democrat many bring the poison
drugs that take the lives of hundreds of
thousands of Americans a primer 90% of
heroin used in this country comes
through the southern border and Mexico
thumbs its nose at us and says your
people asked for it I got an idea it's
time to play hardball the foreign aid to
those countries Guatemala Honduras and
El Salvador some 464 million dollars in
foreign aid from us ended Congress needs
to stop the flow of our money to them
and if they need it so badly use it to
take care of the poverty and the
victimization in their country and I am
sick and tired of people telling us to
have a heart we have a heart we are the
most generous country in the world in
1986 Ronald Reagan gave all illegals
amnesty but amnesty
does nothing but create an incentive for
additional crossings by illegals and so
here we are again and for all of you who
want to trash President Trump I've got
even more news for you
Presidents Bush and Obama sent the
military to the border to the tune of
1.3 billion dollars and it's time to do
it again so let me be clear when you
cross the border into these United
States illegally expect to be arrested
you do not have the right to come here
we did not invite you here you cannot
stay here and on your way out you can
tell the Democrats George Soros and the
angry mob that's coming here you either
come the right way like everyone else or
be ready to face the military and a
one-way ticket back to where you came
from and that's my open